all empires must come to an end
eventually and one such decades deceased
Empire is that of the Dutch which was
given the size of the Netherlands and
how much his neighbors wanted to kill it
pretty impressive but what happened to
this Empire why did it collapse and what
ultimately killed it so the Dutch Empire
was a slow growing one and at the turn
of the 19th century it looked like this
although it wasn't long before Britain
grabbed most of it this was due to the
Netherlands fall - in subsequent
alliance with Napoleon and so Britain
sought to cut off any revenue stream
which might aid him now Britain made it
abundantly clear the seizure of these
colonies was only temporary until
Napoleon was gone after which all of
them would be returned now strictly
speaking Britain could have taken all of
them instead it opted to return these
colonies to the new larger United
Kingdom of the Netherlands because it
wanted it to be a strong buffer state
between France and Prussia so it wasn't
long before Belgium happened but the new
smaller Netherlands still held its
global Empire of which by far the most
important colony was the Dutch East
Indies or Indonesia as is now known the
revenue from these islands was
absolutely crucial to the Dutch who used
it to rapidly develop their own
territories however this meant that the
Dutch largely neglected and ignored the
remaining Caribbean territories the
Antilles and Suriname these were mostly
your standard plantation territories and
after the abolition of slavery they
helped little economic importance to the
Dutch and so we're left to languish the
makeup of the Dutch Empire changed
little until World War two when things
started to head south 1940 so the
Netherlands conquered and his government
flee into exile during the war the
government concerned itself with the
affairs of the Dutch Indies and it was
accepted by many in government that
after the war the relationship between
the Netherlands and its Eastern jewel
would need to change their opinion
stopped mattering in 1942 though when it
fell to the Japanese who installed
native leaders to govern the colony and
the man appointed for the Dutch East
Indies was sakano who worked with the
Japanese in order to stop the Dutch from
returning after the Japanese surrender
and the war was over so Carnot declared
Indonesian independence which led to a
protracted and brutal four-year war in
which the Dutch attempted to retake the
islands at first they were supported by
the United Kingdom but soon after global
and public opinion changed against them
continued resistance at the American
threat of withholding marshal plan aid
when that in 1949 the Dutch recognized
Indonesian independence not all of it
though the Dutch maintained their hold
on New Guinea
so as of 1949 the Dutch Empire was
pretty small and the government knew
something needed to be done to stop the
rest of it falling apart
it was decided that in 1954 the
remaining Western colonies would be
formally incorporated into the new
tripartite kingdom of the Netherlands as
equal members and it was a is after this
that the Dutch gave up any claims on New
Guinea and arguably since the rest of
the territories were now a formal part
of the Netherlands proper the Empire was
then dead
Suriname would become independent in
1975 this time peacefully in the
remaining Dutch holdings would stay a
part of the Netherlands until today to
conclude the Dutch Empire was killed by
its own lack of capability in the
changing attitudes of the post-war world
five years of poor exile crippled the
Dutch ability to maintain a colonial
foothold the new cold war meant the
colonialism as a concept became
unacceptable and within this new
framework the Dutch incorporated their
empire into their own territory the
Dutch Empire was dead or perhaps simply
rebranded I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching but
thanks to my patreon supporters whom you
can see on screen now plus with an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette
Danny Maloney coolin Castleman party
Boyko Rob Waterhouse Mo Aaron the white
Michael Reynolds Chris wicker Gustav
Swan ash way and Emperor Gareth Turner
David Silverman spinning three plates
Maggie packs Kowski Christian check a
Spencer Lightfoot
Winston k-word Anthony Beckett Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn Skye Chappell
and Ike